trong thời gian ra đại hội mì bộng của Đảng, tại chúng ta bao chi đã có gần sáo tranh phục viên.
Kỹ thuật viên thuộc 1 trong Mỹ-Bà có quan bao chi trong nước và gần 1 trong Phuên,
trợi bao chi thuộc 4 bà hàng thực tận bao chi nước ngoài,
phục viên vật kiểu, phố viên các chính đảng lặng tham chính tham dựa tiền về đại hội.
Mại chi có man hình dân, với tính thần trên nghiệm cao cũng đàn góp sức lãng toạ,
trên tại thông tiền về đại hội một cách ký thời, đầy đụ chính sác, không phố và sinh đậu.
Trong có chình đời nơi tin tại đại hội thì mang thị sử dụng trình đời tập trung là đưa những phí sử dự kirt chính của đại hội dẫn ra đồng thời là phố hợp
Các bạn nghĩ kích vừa bình nhau để làm sao mà kuyên chuyển kì. Nhanh nhất, người tin mai của đại hội về kịt thời nơi sống của mà tin mà kì thế sử.
Nạc biệt là trong có chình tắc như tại đây thì chúng tôi cũng luôn là chủ động của hợp với nhau.
Hãy có thích thông tin về nạn của nó cửa nên ra là mẹ bụt tại đây có lực lượng bông trong vào bông ngoài.
Tại móc kì đại hội đang thông tin, tuyên chuyển có vai chào đặc biệt quan trọng.
Đưa với đại hội miệng bún, cùng với các tơ quan thông tính mà chí trong nước mà cũng thế mà chí con quan nên dân đất tập trung thông tin những điểm mới trong công tác tụt chức đại hội và các bạn kịt đại hội.
Nhất là những đột phá của đại hội lên này như tổng bị thư tô lâm đánh nhìn mạnh thạch phía khai mặt này hội.
Tâm yên phải chứ lục, tư duy phải đột phá hành động và quyết liệt.
Mới đá giọt phương tiện, các thức trình tài thông tin về đại hội chính các nên tạm bảo chi có quan nên dân.
Đến được lan phà một cách kì thôi, đây đủ chính sác, không phủ và sinh động trong những ngày vô qua.
Bảo quan tình tâm tất rất nhiều đổi mối, trong đó hội mới lên nhất đó là đã ra xin trang của đại hội đàn.
Bảo quan tình ra bột trong xú ít tờ bảo mà có xin trang của đàn ở đàn.
Để thực hiện bước xin trang ngày thì ngoài các cái công tin về lần đạo đàn nhắn nước, các cái thông tin về...
Bình tởi đưa thông tin về sự đổi mối của đất nước, cũng như thành thử của bún,
nhưng nó có một người đường đồng tình tâm tình tìm về khob công nghệ,
cũng có những người khác về chi đạo định đứng lớn của đàn nhắn nước.
Bảo chúng tôi là có thức đệ,
và ngồi nguyện đưa tình tâm tình tâm tình đầy bảo,
và đặc biệt chú trọng về phần đi gái.
Bộ nguồn, có quan nên rất là díng bảo,
có có có lúc được hát lỗi, chúng ta có đàn bảo,
và linh đồng trong bảo vệ các đồng gí đuệnh lấy đạo, các càng của nạn, đo nước, khai khu tiến.
Tại Trung tâm bảo chí của đá hộ Mề Bún, lấy đạo đạo, nhà nước, các bộ ngành,
lấy đạo bộ công man đã triếp tiếp cập gỡ, dành sự quan tâm động viên,
đánh ra cao tinh thần, chắc nhận của đựu cũng phó viên bảo chí, trong đó có bảo chí công man.
Ná có nhiều nỗ lực, cô gắng tin chuyển nhiều qua, lăn tòa khi thời những nội giống của đại hội đến các tần lớp nhân dân.
Từ đó, có phần tạo sự đồng thận xá hội và niềm tin của các bộ, đằng viên,
nhưng rất nội với thành công của đại hội Mề Bún, đại hội bản lấy mỏ ra khi quyền mới của giống tông.
Đại từ hoàn bảo chí của chúng ta đã có sự đợi hấp dẫn,
sự đợi hấp dẫn, chúng ta có giống và có kế quật rất là vài bản và thù hút được,
có sự quan thăm của nông đảo, các thần lớp nhân dân tham gia và đại dinh hướng làm rõ,
giống giác được những ý vấn đề mà đe dân quan thăm để những dân biểu sâu biểu rõ hơn và tìm tưởng và tháng lợi của sinh nghiệp mạnh tạng ngày càng cao hơn.
Và cuộc tương sớm, trình bị tạng viện, trên khai công việc một cách bài bản và có kế hoạch trời,
báo chí công man nhân dân cùng đồng đảo của quan trình thông trong nước và cuộc tế,
năng hóp sức, tất cả vi thành công của đại hội đạo lần đứng Mề Bún.